Welcome, everyone. This is the Active
Inference Institute quarterly roundtable
number three in 2022. It is September
28, 2022.
Welcome to the active inference
institute. The Active Inference
Institute is dedicated to learning,
researching, and applying active
inference. You can find us at some of
the links here on this slide. This is
recorded in an archived Livestream, so
please provide us with feedback so we
can be improving our work. All
backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome, and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams today
in the quarterly Livestream number
three, we are going to have three broad
action. They won't be too long. There
will be a lot of time. If you want to
add any other notes in the live chat or
maybe even if anybody wants to say hi
in live chaos and join the Livestream
itself. We're going to first have
institute scale updates. We'll talk
about some changes in development at the
institute level. We'll then talk about
projects and the education and research
endeavors that we've been involved in
and that have been developing over this
quarter. And then we'll close with some
next steps and affordances for getting
involved. Let's go first to
the Active Coherence Institute AII
updates at the institute scale. All
right, I'll just give some overview,
and then Alex or Yvonne, feel free to
add more. We're continuing to work with
Fried Frank in a pro bono capacity to
help with the legal side of formalizing
our incorporation as a nonprofit.
We are formalized in terms of what
members we have, our five founding
members, and some of our governance
structures. Currently, we are on the
stage of selecting and electing the
Board of directors. So at this point,
at the end of September 2022, we are
extremely active seeking self
nominations, as well as suggestions for
people who might like to serve in the
Board of directors, especially with
expertise or experience serving on board
of directors for nonprofits,
and any other relevant experience
related to governance, financial,
nonprofit education, and research.
Following the selection of the Board of
Directors, the board will then select
officers who are in more of a direct
operations role at the institute. And
we've also joined the Delaware Alliance
for Nonprofit Advancement Dana to
provide us with access to nonprofit
resources and support. Alex or Yvonne,
want to give any comments?
If you're talking, Alex, you're muted,
but I see yellow.
Okay,
carrying forward,
we are continuing to develop our
institute branding. First, we are
working with some external expertise on
some logo and brand redesigns for the
institute. This is really exciting, and
more will be announced when the work
here is ready to be shown. So enjoy the
black, white, and red and the current
fonts and layouts that we have while you
can. They'll still be there. They'll
still be around. And we've also updated
our website with a restructured short
description of the institute, which I'll
just read now and then. Alex Ravon,
please make any extra comment or provide
any context. The Active Inference
Institute is dedicated to learning,
researching, and applying active
inference. We provide avenues for
connection and integration with broad
audiences and disciplines. Active
Inference Lab Institute provides a
setting for people to aid each other in
pursuit of a better understanding of
active inference. The Institute
organizes education, research and
communication to advance the progress
and public awareness of frontier
knowledge in active inference and
closely related topics. Restructure our
strategy with the building blocks of
participatory, open science,
accessibility and service to our
epistemic community.
Yes, Yvonne. Yes. Sure.
As and institution, we are educated to
having understanding in broad
audience about active inference, what is
it, how we
can use it, and as
we know that active coherence is
applicable for a lot of field
and domain, we are
open to the community from all
of those Fields and domain.
Thanks. Yeah agreed that one of the best
ways for a connection to be made between
active coherence and some other field is
kind of the micro agreement. When people
from that field get involved and get
involved in learning, and then they'll
see all these affordances for connecting
active coherence theoretically and in
practice to their area. It's not like
there's just a tree and the connections
are ready to be pulled at first site.
It takes a little integration and
including different communities in the
conversation. So that's what we're happy
to be building and working on and also
in a participatory way where people's
feedback is really welcome and people's
engagement is essential. So we'll
continue with a few more notes on the
institute scale, and then we'll talk
more about projects that are happening
at the institute, all of which people
can get involved in if they would like.
So, just a structural note. As a
summary, the focus and functions of our
institute are research, education,
outreach, and engagement and methods.
And these Foci are playing out across
multiple scales. There's the participant
scale, which is the human and their
engagement with the institute. There's
the institute scale, which is the system
of interest that we're able to enact
policy in at the institute level. And
there's our broader epistemic community,
which includes the really exciting and
growing active inference community and
all the amazing developments happening
in that area, as well as more broadly
and more distantly.
Many Adjacencies that have been
identified or have not been identified,
ranging from neuroscience and medicine
to machine learning, computer science,
ecology, robotics, all these amazing
areas we have discussions around. And we
have two organizational units that are
kind of like departments. They are
organizational constructions that help
us coordinate projects
and efforts and allocate attention
around our two primary missions in Foci,
which are research and education. So
Edge you active is the organizational
unit that hosts education projects,
whereas the research unit hosts research
projects. And we joked
about having a kind of competition or an
opening of window for renaming. But as
anyone who has watched these roundtables
know we show up on the day of with what
we know that day. So your engagement
or suggestions and ideas are always
welcome and that's how we update,
that's how we learn. But that's just
reflecting some of our structural
learning and updating that's the
institute level. Anything else to add
here? Alex Ravon or we'll continue on to
the project scale.
All right, let's talk first about
education. This is going to be education
at the active inference institute and
project updates over Q three 2022.
First, the active inference textbook
group. So we've been having two
concurrent cohorts of the active
inference textbook group. The first
cohort of the textbook group began in
May 2022 and over the following three
months they completed the first five
chapters of the textbook. And now that
first Conor, the intrepid adventurers,
the early foragers, are continuing on in
chapter six through ten, which is where
the textbook turns towards model
building and recipes for model
construction, which has been really
exciting. And we also in September 2022
began the second cohort of the active
inference textbook group. So this is
some people who are rejoining from the
first cohort as well as many, many new
people joining in. And it's another
concurrence cohort that's starting from
the beginning of the book. So this is
the kind of minimal templating of a
continuous delivery textbook group
format where as more and more people
are interested and curious to learn
about active inference and increase
their familiarity and competency in
engaging and positive social
environments. We will be able to have
the familiarity of people who have
taken the Conor experience of a textbook
group before to then return, for
example, as facilitators or in other
roles, and therefore scale the
continuous delivery of textbook group
experiences around the Par Pazulo Karl
Friston 2022 textbook, but also around
other texts that may be arising.
As we work as a group, we're in a shared
epistemic niche and we provide a whole
host of valueadded services that deeply
enrich your learning. So if you're
currently spending one or more hours per
week or month curious about active
inference, especially curious about this
textbook, your learning and your
contributions will be leveraged if you
join a textbook group cohort we curate
and we compile and address questions
that we're having relating to different
parts of the textbook. And we've created
just an amazing repository of questions
that grows every day and they contain
questions that are confirmatory and
basic, what does this word mean here?
Or what do you think this means? All the
way on up to speculative and research
oriented or application oriented
questions. So questions, questions,
questions are really important part of
learning and they're really important
part of the textbook group. And also
through being in the textbook group,
one becomes more familiar with a variety
of biology scaffolded learning
approaches that we use in the active
inference institute related to our work
from the very beginning with the active
inference ontology. So, for example,
here's equation two five with the
variational free energy. And here we
have just a screenshot of what the
annotation looks like in the
shared knowledge resource in the Coda
for those who are learning and
discussing equation two five. And
there's a whole host of other
information questions that people are
having and what does this mean and what
are the relations to other areas? But
this kind of a learning environment
allows people who have different
backgrounds in math or the formalisms or
in some of these other theoretical
domains that come into play in
relationship with active inference to
have a really exciting space where we're
all learning a ton. So it's been awesome
to have two coherent cohorts going in
the textbook group. And we're looking
forward to in the close of 2022,
to have the first cohort complete the
book and then have a second cohort get
up to the midpoint. And then in the
beginning of 2023, we will likely
continue with the second cohort,
chapter six through ten, and begin a
third cohort and see where things are
ant in the active inference world then.
Any comments or thoughts on the textbook
group? Yeah, sure.
Textbook group is very valuable
tradition for education, and when
you learn something and you get feedback
from your peers, you have more
understanding. And in our groups,
we are providing a lot of useful
instruments that help to understand
not so clear theory as
active inference.
Awesome. And one kind of note or seed
for the future is the textbook is open
source, which is awesome. It increases
the accessibility and downloadability,
but it also offers some incredible
future opportunities in terms of
remixing the book, transposing Axel
constant into GitHub, rerendering
translating, doing some amazing
secondary work with a textbook, and
again, seeing that as templating for
future versions or other textbooks. So
that's a textbook group on where's we
go. Once again, the main
goal of this activity is to help
understand our main idea. And we
plan to do this activity on a regular
basis, and you can join us wherever you
want and wherever you are ready. Thank
you, Yvonne. Very true. All right,
in July 31,
2022, we had our second applied
active inference symposium on robotics.
There were two live streams of about 4
hours each, and there were a handful
of co organizers from within the
institute. And from outside the
institute. We had a whole range of
formats presentations, roundtables and
discussions. The two sessions are shown
here, and when somebody else
is talking, make sure to post links in
the YouTube live chat so people can go
check them out or they're available just
on our Livestream Costa page.
There were about nine presentations
of around 20 to 30 minutes each, people
talking about specific applications of
active inference. So if you're wondering
where is active inference being applied
or how can active inference be applied,
this symposium gives nine case studies
and settings from the robotics domain
where active inference is being applied
today and tomorrow. And at the end of
each session, we also had a round table
discussion that was really interactive
and connected the dots and provided
some context beyond the more research
oriented presentations that were
happening for the bulk of the
presentations. So for those who are
interested in applications of active
inference or in robotics, this was a
really exciting event. And this is also,
we hope, a tradition to continue applied
active inference symposia where people
who want to co organize or present on
their applications in knowledge
management or in medicine or
in ecology, we can convene
and coordinate around the symposium and
have exafferent formats. So we're
currently working to transcribe the
products of this symposium and make them
citable proceedings.
Any thoughts you have on this ethylus?
I think that robotics in terms
of applied field is one of
the most straightforward application
active inference lab, and possibly
in future providing real
breakthroughs in results of robots that
will be active inference lab work for
robotics, cognition and so on.
And as we Sajid from web
communication, there are different
groups of researchers all over the
world. We are interested in
communication, we are interested in
presenting results, and hopefully
more people next years will join
in with active inference robotics
movement and some dates. In some days in
the close future, we'll see really
great application and autonomous
robots based on active inference.
Awesome. Thank you. All right,
speaking of the active inference
journal, so the goal of the active
inference journal is to increase the
accessibility and the indexability,
citability and utility of live streams
and various audio visual material
produced in and around the active
inference institute. So currently we've
been working on around four specific
streams and events to improve and
template our process that we're hoping
to build and scale on. Further, what we
do in the journal is we take the
outcomes of the Livestream, the audio
visuals of the Livestream, and we get a
primary artificial intelligence
Aigenerated transcript and then engage
in a sequence of enrichments, editing
and curations. So we edit the
transcripts by listening carefully to
the audio and making sure that the
speaker's sense is to the extent
possible, captured. And then we also
develop, for example, appendices and
other scholarship around the document.
So when somebody mentions a paper or
when somebody mentions a person, those
kinds of information can be included and
the discourse can be connected to the
active inference ontology in cases where
the terms are being used. And again,
that will enable more accessible
searching in the language of the
live stream. For example, people have
asked questions that somebody might want
to query again or might want to hear
someone's response at a given time too,
and cite that or just learn from it.
And then also it's really important to
have such standardized pipelines for
transcription in order to ensemble
translation into different languages.
Ways that you can get involved in a
journal if you're interested or curious.
In this area, whether you have editing
or proofreading experience or not,
there are many affordances to edit
transcripts. So listening carefully to
the audio and providing suggested edits
on texts. And also we're especially
interested to research and develop
methodologies for the journal process.
So anyone familiar or curious about AI
assisted transcription in translation,
modular implication, decentralized
science and DSI, the usage of Git as a
versioning system, any of these areas,
we would welcome your engagement in the
journal project because that's the
direction that we want to head. And that
is what is going to unlock some of the
potential of the 200 plus live streams
that we've already carried out and the
many hundreds that we'll carry out in
the future. It will enable these past
and future live streams to be able to be
searched, cited, translated, and used
more broadly. So, if you want to join
the meetings for the journal project,
they're on Mondays at 13 UTC in our
discord. So, a few next
steps I mentioned before, but I'll just
give a quick shout out to At Clopath,
who recently for the Lex Friedman
podcast spun up a site using the OpenAI
Whisper platform and made transcripts
for all Lex Friedman episodes. And so
we imagined something similar, because
in our Coda for
the live streams, we have 200 plus
journal discussions, research,
presentations, we are ready to be Open,
AI, Whispered or other pipelines.
So if that's something you're curious
about, or Karpathy or others, if you
want to come get involved, you're
absolutely welcome. There's a lot of
learning and accessibility and rigor
that can be improved with these kinds of
rapidly emerging text engineering
developments. Any other comments you
want to make on active journal?
Yes, and this 200 plus videos,
there are a lot of useful
information that's very available, and
if it will be extracted, it will move
forward.
Totally agreed. There's ways of saying
and conversing in the live streams that
certainly are clearer restatements
of and developments beyond what is
in the written literature. So especially
as we move towards a multimedia future
and a more participatory and inclusive
science sector, it's important that we
have the systems in place with
low human bandwidth to be able to
improve and distribute scholarship on
these topics.
All right, moving on to the live streams
themselves. So we had one month off in
July from live streams where we just
chilled read other papers, not these
papers. And then we've had a bunch
of great live streams so far in Q Three.
We had guest streams with Brett
Anderson, with Ronan Tamari et al. And
with John Verveki. And we discussed
papers in the Live Stream series
on active cognition, abductive logic,
active inference lab, and active
inference as ecological communication.
We also have a wide range of really
interesting live streams coming up,
including on Bayesian mechanics on
neural networks, on all kinds of areas
of active inference, application and a
lot of really exciting theoretical
developments also. So if you want to be
involved in live streams in the YouTube
live chat you'll find the past and
encoding streams. So one way to get
involved is to watch, listen, share,
comment and be involved. That way, if
you want to play a role, for example,
speaking on a live stream or helping
contribute to the preparation around a
live stream, that can also be incredibly
important. As well as making connections
and recommendations for whom we should
invite so that we can have a really
powerful and diverse range of guest
dreams and papers selected for the live
streams. So Live Streams have continued
in their educational function and just
wanted to highlight each one of these
projects. There have been many people to
mention and I hope that we can by
next quarterly lab meeting have some
clearer pathways for making those clear.
But just wanted to in bulk acknowledge
everybody who contributes to the weekly
meetings for live stream preparation and
organizing and those who join the stream
as well as those who help prepare
content and coordinate questions for the
live stream in the background and may
not be on the video themselves,
so that's the live streams we continue
on there. Any other comments?
Just once again, one obvious
thing the more you
involved in and of
our activity and Live Streams is
extremely useful for understanding,
to see the way of application affect
this coherence, why you are engaged and
why you understand this topic.
Great point. And sometimes just
scanning the titles of the papers that
we discussed in the 50 papers that we
have discussed, almost 50 by the end of
the year. These are curated
selections, usually with the authors
joining and almost always with a dot
zero video where people who cared made
background and context to make it as
accessible as possible. So this is a
unique learning resource. If you have a
regime of attention and availability or
capacity for these topics or you're
curious and think you might, it's going
to be a really unique learning resource
for you to check out our past videos.
And then if you're curious about media
production, communication, you want to
explore short formats, you'd like to
facilitate a discussion in a English
language, you want to make an animation
video. There's so many affordances that
we can support. So if you're curious
about those areas, just get in touch.
Okay? Continuing on education,
internal systems thinking, ongoing
activity yvonne, I'll let you describe
it. Thanks.
Yes, we also have not
actually related active
inference our activity and
this August we launched
four weeks session for System Thinking
course, part of it that related to
the role concepts.
For four weeks we
can't cover the whole course, but four
weeks for understanding role concept is
fair enough.
We also run this October
next Cohort and for previous
one, we have good feedback
from our participants.
Could you show next slide,
please? Thank you.
Next. This October, we start new
cohort and here is a link
for participation. It will
also take four weeks,
and during these weeks we
consider concepts from System Thinking
course and we'll
apply these concepts to your
projects or maybe even
live projects. And next
one, we have this activity
with our partner, institute for
Advanced Intelligence and
Entrepreneurship, Engineering and
Management. And this fall,
the EAM Institute launched for
courses. Now, these courses are
available for free, and we also
encourage you to discuss
these courses. For sure you will find
a lot of useful information also related
to the active inference as
evolutionary theory.
Awesome. Yes. So this Systems
Engineering and Systems Thinking
activity helps us learn about roles
and how to apply them in projects. And
we are applying them in Active Inference
institute projects. So it also upskills
participants and gets them ready to take
on more involved and responsible roles
in our institute. And it's all a
coevolutionary dance. As the institute
formalizes and gains resources and
establishes itself in the niche, then
such roles will also be the ones that we
can support. All right,
any other comments onto
the research? So the previous updates
were from Education. Just to briefly
summarize textbook group two ongoing
cohorts active Inference Robotics
Symposium with 8 hours of presentations
and discussions. Active Inference
Journal working towards accessibility
and indexability of all of our speech
products, live streams, continuing and
Systems Thinking education activity
ongoing open to all of these projects.
Your involvement on to the research?
So, it's been a great quarter for
research. First, we'd like to highlight
our active block Force development.
Activeblock Force Instance is an open
source package that is implementing
classic and novel active inference
ModelStream within the system simulation
framework of Cadcat. So we have a few
updates on active blockerents. First,
Jacob Smithall presented a poster
at the Iy 2022 3rd International
Workshop on Active Inference. So
congratulations, Jacob, for this awesome
poster, presenting it in person, and to
all others who have been contributing to
development on Active blockfronts. It's
really great to see the development of
this project and also a lot of other
work in the active inference community.
So please check out Iy if you're curious
to see what is cutting edge active
inference lab research. They really did
a great job in getting some of the best
projects in the space.
Also, Active Lock Force Instance has
received some funding through
the Bitcoin Gr 15 round that just
completed. So our Agent COVID project
was Active Lock Force Instance, an open
source package for cognitive modeling in
web three. And we
specifically framed how we could utilize
cognitive modeling approaches
integrating active inference and CAD CAD
for cognitive modeling in web Three
ecosystems. So big appreciation to
everyone who provided even $1
to this funding opportunity. And in
several weeks, we'll know the final
amount that we've received after the
quadratic funding algorithms have all
been applied, but suffice to say that we
have some money in our tank to
develop active block prints. So there
are many ways in Brea people can get
applied in. There are weekly meetings,
there are weekly meetings at twelve and
17 UTC on Wednesday in the discord. And
also we discussed this with Yaccup
today. Mondays at 18 UTC is
going to be a code development specific
session. So if you want to get a little
bit more technical and collaborate with
Markov and others on the Cadcad
active inference modeling, then Mondays
18 UTC is a great synchronous time at
twelve and 17 UTC on Wednesdays. Those
are slightly more open sessions where we
can also split off and have technical
development, but we talk about a whole
range of areas. So I'm going to mention
some areas and then tasks and how we're
going to use some of our funding to
accelerate development. These are just
showing a few of the areas where we
believe cognitive modeling could be used
or might be important or relevant to
consider, ranging from a range of social
settings, education,
governance, legal, online work,
stigma, G, so on, to a
host of Web Three cases. So Dows,
Decentralized, finance, D, school,
DSI, Ethereum, a lot
of other areas in Web Three, and then
also on the ground with
the ants in terms of developing the
active infra ant model for ant colony
foraging and ultimately larger task
allocation questions. These are all
areas where we see the active
blockfronts package as being able to
address them eventually. And what it
takes to address an active block force
instance model in one of these cases and
settings is for someone with domain
expertise or knowledge to provide the
bridge building from one side and then
the package to develop the generalized
capacities from the other side. So we're
working from both ends to enable really
powerful domain specific implication of
active inference while building modular
structure of the active blockfront
package so that those functionalities
can be used in other settings. For
example, a navigation setting that might
arise from our work on ant foraging
might be used in a different context in
another nonant setting. So that's a
little bit about how we approach the
development of the package. We think
about the functionalities of the
package, modulars as modules that can be
invoked and functions that can be
called, and then we develop different
settings. For cognitive modeling. There
are a range of tasks that people can get
involved in ranging from Cadcat and
active inference technical tasks, to a
whole host of package level and
documentation and community engagement
tasks. So if this sounds like a cool
direction or you would just like to
learn more, then please join a
synchronous meeting or get in touch
another way, because this is a super
exciting area of development. We hope
that active blockfronts can be a really
important package in this area and so
come be involved with the funding.
What we're going to be experimenting
with in the coming weeks and months is a
task based payment scheme.
So individuals or small teams will
propose how much funding they would like
to receive for what specific tasks, and
there's a form that will be filled out.
And so we can show you that if you join
Synchronously, completing that form will
raise your task request to
consideration. And then if the task is
approved and you complete it as laid
out, you will be paid the amount that
you requested. So if funding ever felt
like it was a rate limiting step for
your involvement in learning or applying
active inference and contributing to
open source public goods, then consider
it differently now, because we can
support this type of work. And we
also see some really exciting
opportunities for people, for example,
to propose tasks around applying to
other grants or to including more
developers or more documenters,
or people who want to make Active Block
Force its live streams. There's a
million areas where people can develop
here, so join the weekly meetings is the
best way to get involved there. Any
other comments on blockfronts?
Okay, then, just one last
research update. This is not presenting
all the research happening in the
institute. This is just to kind of raise
a few projects up. We have had
a project on cognitive modeling
framework and their comparisons. The
goal of this project is to understand
similarities and differentiate with
active coherence and other cognitive
modeling framework. So the approach that
we're taking here is to review and
assess different cognitive modeling
frameworks in terms of their features,
their functions, their elements, their
areas of application, and so on.
And that will help us understand
similarities and differences amongst
frameworks, as well as more formally
and historically integrate active
inference with other models. So this is
one of a research task that could
open up quite broad vistas for
application. Anyone who's curious or
engaged in cognitive modeling would be
welcome to get involved with this
project. And one can even see the
pathway here, kind of like the epistemic
chaining example in Pi MDP.
If someone identifies that there is a
common cognitive modeling framework that
has features ABC and is used in domain
F, then domain F
becomes an area of application for
active inference. If functions ABC
can be implemented better in active
inference than the initial framework.
So that kind of work on the landscape of
cognitive modeling is a really important
precursor to understanding where and how
and with an emphasis on which
functionalities it even makes sense to
talk about applying active inference.
And we hope and expect to prefer that
there will be active inference
applications that haven't been within
the range of traditionally considered
cognitive settings. For example, I'm not
sure how often in multiscale ecology
cognitive modeling frameworks are used
as a simulation tool. Now we know
that active inference. Is being applied
in those areas, but there are also areas
where cognitive modeling is already
happening and it may or may not be using
active inference. So those represent
adjacencies where by developing the
connection between how they're doing it
today and how it could be done,
people will be opening up really large
areas for active inference application
and also massive areas of attention and
support. So this is kind of a cool
direction. Any notes on this or anything
else on research?
All right, let's just go to some last
steps and close. If anyone in the live
chat has any questions, they're welcome
to add them. So, next steps
for the Institute? Well, on the
engagement and outreach frontier,
we continue to grow and develop.
We host most of our communication at our
discord, which has over 450 members.
Now, our Twitter as well as our
podcast and video channels are all
growing in terms of their niche.
So if you support us on any of these
platforms and can share or just even
tell one person, that can be quite
helpful. And always provide us with
feedback on how we can improve our
environment, our agreement with external
interfaces, and then just to provide
a summary of some steps and directions
for how we go from Q Three on beyond to
Q Four, any of these areas.
If you are interested or curious,
please be involved. The earlier and the
more involved, simply the better and the
higher leverage point that is for the
future. We are continuing education and
research. It's the main focus of active
inference lab Institute, and we will
always continue education and research.
We're also, during these months
undergoing a really creative and unique
organizational development opportunity,
for example, around assembling the board
of directors and some of the early
decisions around governance and
organizational structure. So if you have
input or want to be more involved here
as well, otherwise just to know that
it's happening. We are looking towards
several directions ant the end of 2022
and to really come into in
a new way in 2023. We're looking towards
increased participation in projects and
learning groups, as well as the
development of an internship program
that will help structure your engagement
with a mentor and in a project specific
way so that you can stay engaged and
also have something clearer to point to
about your engagement with the
Institute. We are continuing to,
as we finish the first cohort of the
textbook group, think more and more
about active coherence course
developments. So we'd encourage anyone
who wants to partner or be involved in
that area to get in touch in
the journal project and in a slightly
different way in the textbook group.
We're working towards the captioning,
the subtitles and language translations
where possible. And especially with our
new organizational structure, we're
looking towards funding opportunities
and partnerships. So if you have any
thoughts or capacities or feedback
in these Brea, they're all super
important areas for the institute going
forward and it would be really
appreciated as we are a participatory
open science institute and only recently
received our first small amount of
funding through the Agent Coin grant for
blockfronts to explore new
avenues of partnership, funding,
service and beyond that we have not
done. So what hasn't happened yet is
not too strong of a prior on what we may
do in the future, if that makes sense.
We'll be doing different things and I
hope that you can be a part of it
because it grows and changes in
coengagements when and only when
people get engaged. That's
interactionism, this is not
instructionism. So if you have any
excitement around these topics or any
others that you would want to have on
here, then getting in contact with us
will be a great first step. Join our
discord, join any of the synchronous
meetings, email us and we can
start a conversation that way.
Well, that is all for this roundtable.
It was a short quarter, it was
only like a few months from
our previous Livestream. Time went by
quite fast and a lot did
happen. So once again,
next quarter promises to. Be more
active and as you understood,
they are very open to participation.
So in the class, see you on our
synchrony meetings in this course.
Subscribe us and share.
Yes? Alex, any last comments?
I can only repeat that the participation
of people who will join
us in the future is the main focus for
us and everything what we are doing is
related to help others to
learn about active coherence, to learn
active coherence and find ways to apply
it. And we are on open
ended path and actually we
don't know what will be in three months
from here but we will adaptive and
provide possible
affordance for hours to join and learn.
So welcome indeed,
welcome to those who are and haven't
joined yet and a big appreciation again
for everyone who's contributed to the
Institute to make things how they are
today. So thanks everyone. Alex,
see you later. Thank you. Thank you.